both worked for Clint Eastwood I just
had one big scene in a movie yeah what
was your scene I haven't seen that it's
it's no one saw it it's called Midnight
in the Garden good and evil I had like a
scene where they cross-examined me but
it you know it's a lot of great actors
Jack Thompson and you know Spacey and uh
Cusack and I'm being cross-examined it's
my first role in a movie and you know I
I'm playing a character and it was just
holy [__] but like for you and I
remember how I felt it's like look at
this this is my first movie were you
like when he's like all right Paul
here's what I want you to do on this one
if you could show a little a little bit
more vulnerability but don't give it to
them don't make them see it try to make
it like it's done you know it's a
private moment that's uh that's that's
really good I mean were you like um in
the beginning like oh my God Clint East
was directing me it was um no because he
would never say that many words
[Laughter]
glint's whole thing was minimalism and
exactitude which you know I appreciate
Spike Lee does the same thing so it
didn't have a lot of notes
no the only notes he ever gave me uh
were
uh speed like pacing like Paul Thomas
Anderson made fun of Phil Hoffman on the
set of Magnolia he's like he's like this
is how I get up and look at a framed
photo on a table he walks up takes three
seconds to walk up looks at it goes hmm
and sets it back down it's all of eight
seconds he goes here's how Phil does it
and then he walks up and he's like
looking around for like 30 seconds
God gets the photo discovers the photo
so it has like a moment where he's about
to cry like I I kind of got caught doing
that on Richard Jewel a couple times and
and Clint would walk up to me and go ah
it needs a little more uh
Skip to My Lou Skip to My left Pace it
up and I'd be like oh man the boss is
right and by the way I would say eight
or nine out of ten times he was right
and I was milking something uh it mostly
unconsciously and then once in a while
I'd be like uh this like
this is a big this is a big moment I
think the editor should find the pacing
I need to honor this moment and really
feel the breadth of it and make sure
that there's an origin to the conclusion
because some scenes it's like you should
have seen the original screenplay
Billy Ray wrote a great script no shock
there he's Billy Ray but they had me
Richard Jewell crying like three or four
times in the movie and I was like I
can't
we can't have me crying that many times
it's gonna take all the power out of it
and you know doesn't it make more sense
to let it build I'll get choked up
uh when my mom starts getting emotional
because I'm mad that this is affecting
my mother you're right you've got a
little thing there but then we saved it
for the end and we really let the the
damn kind of burst and break